SCP-096 Vs SCP-1361. SCP-096
may be an unstoppable force,
but will SCP-1361, the all-devouring mass of
animal meat slurry, be an immovable object?
We all know SCP-096 is tough: It
shrugs off the biggest guns we have,
can move at lightning speed, and can track
down targets like a heat-seeking missile.
SCP-1361 is a giant roving blob of meat
that absorbs and digests its victims,
adding to its ever-growing mass.
But we personally think 096 would bring this one
home. 1361 has the advantage of not having eyes,
and thus, could not activate 096’s rage state.
But, even if 1361 could digest 096’s flesh,
we’d bet money that it couldn’t put
a scratch on the monster’s skeleton.
It would crawl out of the blob and reform,
ready to maim and maul another day.